oh look a nice little Creek a kind of
thing mining its own business
just doing some instant stuff how about
a human hand for scale there you go
there's some good perspective these are
wedded they were the heaviest confirmed
insects on earth
thankfully they only live in New Zealand
there's actually several different kinds
of Wetty and a largest among them is
actually quite peaceful it's about the
size of a gerbil over big and herbalist
but there is one variety among them that
don't take crap from nobody this is the
tree web specifically a tree whether
that's nine on my nominee for
entomologist of the year only males have
these enormous mouth marks not as
mandibles which they use to fight for
females my fight I mean disembody their
rivals lips now relatively speaking
these Wetty aren't that big as far as
animals go I mean I still tower over
them so what's keeping them from growing
to our size well it all has to do with
respiration
they don't have lungs like we do instead
they have holes all over their
exoskeletons the deliver oxygen to the
tissues as the air makes its way through
the animal more and more oxygen gets
dissolved to the tissues at the center
might get shortchanged grow too big and
you might not be able to breathe really
Wetty have only been able to grow so big
because they gave up and white since on
new zealand they never had mammals to
worry about eating them but 300 million
years ago there was much more oxygen in
Earth's atmosphere so insects could
afford to grow to unacceptable sizes
dragonflies size of seagulls so breezy
please gentlemen
breathe them all that oxygen these are
the Wetty can't get out of hand
you